keem and sami are back and coming
to america to america too furious
very excited to check this out i watched
coming to america for the first time
this year alone so it's pretty fresh in
the noggin right about now
anyhoo let's see if this sequel looks
any good
shall we
you must eat my words before i'm gone my
son
[Music]
oh hell no your majesty
man they haven't aged at all no
wesley snipes
[Music]
all these characters are still alive yep
despite how old they worked
again
still got the jerry cross
politically incorrect
i think i know what the twist is what's
the twist
that it's really our senior halls kid oh
that'd be cool and that would make that
would also spiritually i think make some
sense
spiritually well you know because he's
much more attuned to the
royalty lifestyle i think it would make
more sense because
at one point he was pretending to be
eddie murphy's akeem
and then he was sleeping around where as
eddie murphy
was pretty faithful and loyal he was
pining over that one woman who's all
about lisa
i thought he brought back to his people
so that's why i'm like it doesn't make
sense to me if he has
if that if the last time he was in
america
was in the last movie
i feel like it would make more sense
that it would be arsenio hall's kid yeah
because he was sleeping around your
theory holds correct and now i gotta go
back through the trailer and see if we
can count the easter eggs
i mean i think that's not one easter egg
you see the i forget the name of the
characters but in the barber shop it's
right here you see like the jerry curls
and everything like that
i feel like that's a photo that ripped
exactly from those like ads that he was
doing
it looks like like a retro prop or
something like that
i mean this looked better than i
expected it to yeah i mean it definitely
has the energy i mean this pretty much
to me just confirmed the vibe of the
movie and the fact that yeah you're
gonna have
the classic characters back you're gonna
have a couple of fresh faces and a
couple new comedic voices to join in the
ensemble you're gonna have the benefits
of having arsenio hall and eddie murphy
play multiple characters like they did
the first time
like it doesn't really suggest a whole
lot of i don't know really what's new
yeah other than the mission of we gotta
go find your son and you gotta bring him
back here so that he can be king and i
wonder if there will be any parallels to
the first movie with you know
what kind of person he is and if he is
averse to hard work and common life or
not you know like
because there's a lot about breaking
tradition in the first movie and this is
also you know his dad's sending him back
on a tradition-based mission yeah
you know like i'm curious about what the
actual story is gonna really unfold
into but this looks like a lot of fun
and everybody looks like they're in top
form it's fun to see eddie murphy back
in his element i
i hope this is good because of that but
yeah i mean this looks fun i wish they
had cuba goody junior back in the chair
because at this point it's like when
they return back to america everything
looks exactly as they left it
and i thought there'd be a little bit
more like these modern day touches but
the people haven't left
which is kind of the vibe of some parts
of new york and people who are just so
married to there and they're never going
to leave those traditional
folk it would be cool to keep it going
it'd be cool to see samuel jackson make
a cameo again
after being the guy who robbed the fast
food chain and then to see like what his
life has become
since then yeah i think it would be
really great to get a cameo from sam
jack i'm sure i bet they're saving that
i'd be very surprised
especially this director do
um black snake moan brewer
yeah the guy who directed hustle and
flow the combination of it being coming
to america eddie murphy and the director
of black snake moan i'm very i don't
know if i'm correct about that curious
to see what that guy's taking on comedy
it would be very fascinating to see him
return that means it seems like it'd be
possible and i'm also excited for wesley
snipes to be in here because after
seeing wesley snipes work
and dolomite is my name he was
hysterical and him working alongside
eddie murphy
wonderful chemistry so them being here
together james earl jones returning a
little bit heartbreaking to see him in
the bed
well he is older now he's old and i'm
like oh this is breaking my heart
yeah yeah there's some real feels maybe
coming there
but as it stands right now pretty solid
trailer we'll watch it in march what'd
you guys think of the coming to america
2 trailer does it look as promising as
you've been hoping i know this is well
like some people hail this is his
best movie he's ever done so you know i
know that people are very much in an
arsenal home except for him making a
comeback hey man this is the time this
is the big like
he this will bring him back to the
zeitgeist in a major way more than eddie
murphy is what i'm hoping
yeah it's just like the time of arsenio
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that notification
bell hit the like button we'll catch you
guys soon